pagnon voilà puisqu'on parle d'histoire
le sujet qui suit est plein dans le
mille avec la réouverture à versailles
d'une partie des salles du musée de
l'histoire de france longtemps fermé
faute de gardiennage des milliers de
tableaux ils sont présentés qui
illustrent les grands événements du
moyen-âge à marignan jusqu'à la fin de
la première guerre mondiale
une visite à laquelle nous convie gérard
dalmaz 10 millions de visiteurs chaque
année à versailles avec la réouverture
progressive des 125 salles du musée de
l'histoire de france créée par louis
philippe versailles double sa surface
visitable à l'intérieur du château les
cinq sein des croisades n'avait jamais
été montrés au grand prix mais 150
toiles témoignages intacte du goût
artistique mais aussi de la manière de
peindre l'histoire victorieuse de
préférence selon les artistes des années
1830 à 1850 le projet de musée en fait
de lui répéter de montrer un petit peu
toutes les époques de l'histoire de
france est plus glorieuses évidemment
pour rassembler derrière lui
déjà à l'époque voulait rassembler
derrière un président à roye le peuple
de france on y avait des légitimistes
ici avec les croisades les bonapartistes
avec des stations en pire
les républicains avec la pollution
française parce que vous suffit pas
partie des révolutions et puis les
orléanistes avec une licence rome le roi
louis philippe
chapeau bas devant le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge des trois glorieuses et marie
kaddes tableau étonnant dans la fameuse
salle 1830 l'arlésienne jusqu'à présent
voilà donc encore de l'inédit pour le
grand public la prise de pouvoir d
orléans sous l'oeil narquois de
l'inamovible talleyrand quant à la
fabuleuse galerie des batailles grande
comme un champ de tir
elle raconte 35 victoires de tolbiac à
bagram tiré les premiers mais sur les
anglais les batailles du bon maréchal de
saxe et de son monarque louis le
bien-aimé quinzième du nom son arrière
grand papa louis xiv était également
amateur de conquête prise de cambrai
documents précieux jamais exposé est
désormais installée dans la galerie 17e
enfin accessible quant à ce combat de
maastricht d'artagnan est passé de vie à
trépas 40 gardiens engagé pour ces
réouvertures lentement mais sûrement
versailles montre les 15 cents oeuvres
de son musée l'ensemble des
architectures du palais